nicolas vidal bonjour bonjour olivier
bonjour heureux de nous trouver dans la
matinale alors le convoi de la liberté
s'était lancé hier on le disait et va
poursuivre sa progression dès
aujourd'hui qu'est ce qu'on peut en dire
nicolas et oui chez olivier ce matin et
nous allons reparler du comble la
liberté comme la semaine dernière j'ai
envie de vous dire est que aujourd'hui
c'est devenu une réalité que gérald
darmanin prend très au sérieux en tout
cas un peu plus que notre confrère
apolline de malherbe que outrecuidance
imaginez bien de lui poser des questions
sur son bilan catastrophique en matière
de sécurité mais il n'en faut pas moins
un gérald darmanin pour le rendre très
chafouin alors oui tout en haut un sous
les lambris de la place beauvau on
craint l'arrivée sur paris de centaines
voire de milliers citoyen voiture en
compte picard en vieille guimbarde ou à
moto qui pourraient thrombose et bien
entendu la capitale on pourrait appeler
ça la congestion populaire de la france
vérif eric car certains français sont
inventifs et malicieux cas il le faut
surtout surtout pour récupérer leur
liberté la réalité surtout c'est que ce
convoi est passé totalement sous silence
ça on en a parlé il ya quelques jours
émile requis aujourd'hui depuis début la
semaine toutes les attentions de nos
chers médias mainstream
c'est un changement un manifeste de la
stratégie victorienne et qui chaque fois
le cas cas l'impression sur les réseaux
sociaux se fait trop forte telle une
submersion numérique malgré la censure
qui sévit alors oui ce matin cher
olivier nous allons essayer un
décryptage plus politique la semaine
dernière de ce combat des libertés que
je ne m'abaisserai pas définir comme une
initiative populaire anti vagues ce
projet les jeunes est en fait anti tout
car on peut le de pleurer le déplorer ou
s'en réjouir mais ce qu'on voit la
liberté n'est pas seulement une
procession de français qui dénonce en
klaxonnant les seules mesures sanitaires
c'est bien plus profond que cela et ce
matin nous allons essayer de comprendre
pourquoi olivier justement nicolas
politiquement quelle analyse faites-vous
de ce convoi de la liberté
et bien ce qu'on allait liberté en fait
il n'a rien de spontané alors certes il
est évident on l'a vu dans le reportage
précédent que dément déclencheur et nous
vient la situation au canada et au
québec ça c'est incontestable mais sa
genèse doit être pensé à l'aune du
dégradations fulgurant notre métabolisme
démocratique qu'on peut faire remonter
ou du mot que je fais remonter notamment
en 2008 lorsque le grand démocrate
nicolas sarkozy a imposé aux français
rappelez-vous contre leur volonté le
traité le traité de lisbonne est là pour
moi vous avez l'origine d'un divorce
irréversible d'une grande partie des
français avec leurs élites politiques et
médiatiques qui se sont tout simplement
tout simplement assis sur leur
souveraineté c'est à dire qu'on a perdu
depuis près de 15 ans la chose la plus
précieuse en train peuple et sa classe
politique c'est la confiance avec un
grand c est surtout la légitimité
politique et lorsque vous assassinez
cette confiance et que vous bafouez
propre légitimité vous remettez en
profondément en cause par seulement la
république un qui n'est qu'un régime il
faut-il encore le rappeler mais la
démocratie qui est le socle absolument
crucial olivier pour assurer la
pérennité et l'unité d'une nation parce
qu'en réalité il met la démocratie c'est
que des millions de citoyens ont accepté
de déléguer un futur leur souveraineté
de leurs âmes à des dirigeants pour
qu'eux-mêmes préserve la paix l'égalité
la concorde et qu'ils assurent la
continuité historique et surtout qui
défendent leurs intérêts car les
français du convoi de la liberté et
rigides et jaunes entre nous ils n'ont
aucune aspiration révolutionnaire et
encore moins factieuses comme on entend
ça et là en permanence car ces français
en fait ils veulent tout simplement
vivre dignement paisiblement et
s'assurer que leur citoyenneté sera
respecter leur dignité assuré il n'y a
rien de plus que cela mais c'est aussi
été populaire face à une certaine forme
de trahison de nos élites avec ce
référendum 2005 a pris fin avec le
mouvement des gilet jaune et ce qu'on
voit des libertés n'est que la seconde
vague de contestation fins un pouvoir
qui a méprisé on l'a vu insulter et
maltraités maltraite encore d'ailleurs
un des millions de français alors
aujourd'hui ce ne sont pas seulement un
énième soubresaut d'émotion populaire
mais une remise en cause profonde de
légitimité politique et et ceux qui sont
aujourd'hui sur les routes ne semble que
la partie immergée de l'iceberg ça c'est
extrêmement important car il faut
aujourd'hui beaucoup de courage olivier
pour manifester hors des centrales
syndicales et des baraques à frites
entre 14 heures et 17 heures un samedi
et pourtant nicolas la présidentielle
approche grand pas et on pourrait penser
que les français auraient loisirs avec
cette échéance de changer la ligne
politique française eh bien oui vous
avez raison ça c'est la question de fond
c'est la question centrale dans un pays
je vais vous dire dans un pays normal
démocratique ça devrait se passer comme
ça l'élection suprême devrait pernette
que permettre une grande bouffée d'art
démocratique et endiguer les passions
populaires mais ce n'est plus du tout le
cas car des millions de français et là
je parle de la partie une nouvelle fois
émerger les icebergs ont un nouveau
décidé de se montrer et on en revient
toujours à ce naufrage la légitimité qui
ce thème sanctuaire et la perte abyssale
de libertés les plus fondamentales
déjà certains éditorialistes de cour
fondé par les le tropisme et ils nous
refont le coup de l'ingérence étrangère
et de l'extrême droite et la morue de
pouvoir en place contestant les
non-vaccinés n'est pas tout à fait
vacciner n'est que discrimination une
dignité et coercition ce pouvoir n'est
plus que tous les autres réunis à
réguler elle réussit l'odieux forfait
finalement d'écorner la note de la
france et ladite dignité demi en france
et honnête de façon irréversible et
s'enfermer dans cette rhétorique binaire
qui voudraient nous faire croire que
lorsque les français plébiscitent les
pouvoirs en place c'est la démocratie
mais lorsque s'y oppose et du populisme
et tom péril absolument suicidaire alors
que oui comme le disait le regretté jean
gabin je cite à travers les innombrables
vicissitudes de la france de pourcentage
d'emmerdeur est le seul qui n'ait jamais
baissé fin de citation et j'ajouterais
moi surtout gouvernement et j'ajouterai
enfin allez bonne route merci nicolas
l'édito politique de nicolas villa l'a
retrouvée bien évidemment sur les
réseaux sociaux